le vote de la loi l'ensemble des lois
forment une sorte d'édifices immatériels
comme une grande maison qui nous permet
tout simplement de vivre ensemble cet
édifice en perpétuelle travaux tient
debout parce qu'il est ancré sur un
socle solide et quasiment immuable la
constitution dont je vous parle dans un
autre épisode
la loi crée des droits des devoirs
protège ou limitent notre liberté
c'est une décision collective prise par
les représentants du peuple le parlement
au début l'idée d'une loi se trouve le
plus souvent dans le programme d'une
majorité politique ce n'est à ce moment
là qu'une promesse les matériaux de
construction pour ajouter un morceau à
l'édifice sont encore dans les caisses
si c'est un parlementaire qui rédige le
texte
on appellera ça une proposition de loi
si c'est le gouvernement on dira que
c'est un projet de loi une fois rédigé
le texte est soumis au conseil d'état
comme de vingt cabinets de conseils
d'ingénieurs du bâtiment les membres de
cette institution donneront un avis sur
le texte
ils diront s'il est bien écrit si
juridiquement il ne crée pas
d'interférence avec d'autres lois déjà
existantes
bref si les plans des travaux sont
sérieux s'il le faut le parlementaire où
le ministre qui porte la loi rectifiera
son texte en fonction de ce qu à lille
conseil d'état puis le texte passe en
conseil des ministres il est validé par
le président de la république
ok pour les travaux dit il le texte est
alors soumis au parlement la plupart du
temps à l'assemblée nationale il est
d'abord examiné par un groupe restreint
de parlementaires spécialisées dans le
domaine que traite le projet l'économie
la défense ou les questions société par
exemple ce sont les commissions qui
peuvent parfois entendre des
spécialistes qui ne sont pas du monde
politique
ces commissions peuvent modifier un peu
le texte c'est là que les plans des
travaux sont finalisés l'ensemble des
députés peut se mettre au travail le
texte est débattu dans l'hémicycle
l'art des députés de la majorité ou de
l'opposition apportent leur pierre au
morceau de l'édifice que l'on est en
train de construire en déposant des
amendements encore les ajustements des
changements
puis l'assemblée vote le texte celui ci
part alors au sénat les sénateurs le
modifier à leur tour avec leurs
amendements à eux s'il ya trop de
différences entre la version des députés
et celle des sénateurs ont réuni
quelques députés et quelques sénateurs
c'est la commission mixte paritaire
pour qu'ils tentent de s'entendre quoi
qu'il arrive ce sont les députés qui ont
le dernier mot quand la loi est enfin
voter ça ne veut pas dire que les
travaux sont terminés
il manquera les finitions les décrets
d'application ce sont toutes les
précisions décidées par le gouvernement
et qui permettront que la loi soit bien
applicable et trouve sa place définitive
dans l'édifice mais tout ce bel
agencement peut-être brisés si avant la
promulgation par le président de la
république le conseil constitutionnel
dit que le texte est non conforme à la
constitution
c'est à dire qu'il met en danger tout
l'édifice est là il faut tout
recommencer le projet le conseil d'état
le conseil des ministres les commissions
la navette entre les députés les
sénateurs
la commission mixte paritaire le conseil
constitutionnel